je sais que vous avez insisté sur les
violences faites aux policiers
mais est ce que vous pensez qu'il ya un
problème de violence policière est
question dans la question est ce qu'il
ya un problème de formation parce qu'on
parle beaucoup de ce sujet que les
dérapages sont souvent liés à des
policiers qui manquent d'expérience
est-ce que sur ces deux points
vous pouvez répondre évidemment que je
suis au problème formation j'en ai parlé
en première partie ça c'est le point le
plus mauvais au problème comme je
l'expliqué dans la première partie on
est formés pendant un an d'école pour
ceux qui ont eu la chance de faire un an
et après plus rien donc souvent on vient
à être au sol avec des individus
récalcitrants et les seuls que ni qu'on
peut faire c'est comment on appelle
grossièrement du combat de rue
sait on essaie d'interpeller l'autre
essaye de se défendre
ça finit avec un coût pour le policier
un coupon voile un dj et voilà on ne
sait pas faire pour lui pour beaucoup
pas tous il faut arrêter de mettre les
mêmes gens dans panier parce que vous
écoutez vous mettez tout le monde dans
le même panier
là j'ai fait la différence entre la
prise du quotidien et celle du maintien
de l'ordre c'est quoi la défense du
quotidien la différence gardien argentin
comprend le service quand même je suis
désolé mais c'est la police tandis que
le ménage soit il va pas chez vous quand
vous parlez de ses collègues du maintien
gland vous parlez de moi à bastia merci
joua d'un oeil non metro france et la
police du quotidien et merci pour tous
mes copains
merci pour tous les policiers blessés
moi personne ne regarde et au regard de
mon affaire moi j'ai rien fait avant je
vérifie pas dans mon bain amalgames les
35 d'autres personnes mutilées
aujourd'hui donc aucune ne sont
poursuivis pour a fait violence avant de
prendra je pense que vous pouvez pas
être objectif et je n'avais pas être
objectif pour moi je suis mon avis
personnel je pense que vous n'avez pas
être à ses objectifs par rapport à ce
qui faisait passer je peux pas être
objectif parce que j'ai mal dormi huit
aujourd'hui deux policiers qui me
saluent et d'autres qui m'insultent je
n'ai pas dit que vous étiez pas assez
pour objectif que enfin que vous ne
pouvez pas l'être juste que vous parlez
que tous les policiers par exemple de la
brave sont des poulets de chair séparé
sais pas si je vais montre les vidéos
j'ai rempli ma un jour ça lui et m'a
demandé gentiment de la brave qui shoote
avec un aigle vd cayla bouyaka bouyaka
quand ils sont une cible c'est pas des
pourritures ça cela voilà le pas ce
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour les jeter ces
régions mêlant spartoo violence inouïe
se soit mise à part une forme c'est
selon l'agent du milieu que ce soit dans
tous les mutuelles donc bientôt les
faits pour les dénoncer mais jeanne je
voudrais résumer pour vos jeunes c'est
un problème marginal dans la police y
est pas un problème de violence générale
sur la police du maintien de l'ordre en
parle de on parle de cette manière vous
avez fait de leurs frontières on a fait
dix ans en son temps lui de maintien de
l'ordre
je pense être une monnaie que les
policières j'ai jamais eu de problème
avec ma hiérarchie je suis très bien
notée ça m'est déjà arrivé de me mettre
au sol et ça pourrait m'arriver de
fautes et parce que je n'ai pas assez
d'expérience parce que les gens ne sont
pas tendres avec nous et il faut arrêter
de tout temps dire que c'est nous les si
vous allez à la faute de jeunes est ce
que vous allez dire j'ai fauté où vous
allez vous cacher falsifié des documents
oui c'est tout à votre essayer d'inviter
vos collègues faire la même chose j'ai
fait mais influent je ne suis pas mère
je ne suis pas leur père il ya le côté
achète moi mes collègues c'est une
question de famille fut ma famille donc
c'est difficile aussi de 30 cas requis
pour seul le peu qu'ils essayent de
dénoncer au fait jeter à teinture c'est
comme la politique si on n'a pas le même
avis que le voisin d'à côté on a
forcément tort on avance a jamais alors
parfaitement mais jusqu'à encore entre
vous les politiques malheureusement ce
sans problème de police c'est ce que
j'ai dit c'est une période du bras armé
aujourd'hui de leurs erreurs j'ai
seulement